these words say i am the law of thy god which
has brought thee out of the land of egypt
out of the house of bondage thou
shalt have no other gods before me
thou shalt not make unto thee any driven image or
any likeness of anything that is in heaven above
or that is the earth beneath all
that is in the water under the earth
thou shalt not bow down thyself to them nor serve
them for i the lord thy god am a jealous god
visiting the iniquity of the fathers upon the
children unto the third and fourth generation
of them that hate me ensuing mercy unto thousands
of them that love me and keep my commandments
thou shalt not take the name of the lord thy god
in vain for the lord will not hold him guiltless
that taketh his name in vain remember the sabbath
day to keep it holy six days shalt thou labor
and do all thy work but the seventh
day is the sabbath of the lord thy god
in it thou shalt not do any work
thou not thy son nor thy daughter
thy man's servant nor thy maidservant not thy
cattle nor thy stranger that is within thy gates
for in six days the lord made heaven and earth
the sea and all that in them is and rested the
seventh day wherefore the lord blessed the
sabbath day and hallowed it honor thy father
and thy mother that thy days may be long upon
the land which the lord thy god giveth thee
thou shalt not kill thou shalt not
commit adultery thou shalt not steal
thou shalt not bear false witness against thy
neighbor thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's house
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife
nor his manservant nor his maidservant
nor his ox not his ass nor anything that is thine
is god is good and all the time happy sabbath
everyone thank you very much for coming to the
house of god to listen to his word it is my honor
it is my privilege it is my delightful
joy to stand before you to speak for god
i can think of no higher privilege other than
to reflect god in life than to speak for god
it's a very solemn responsibility and my
intention as best as my humanity will permit me
is to give you thus said the lord
prophets and kings page 626 paragraph one
yellow white writes the words of the bible and
the bible alone should be heard from the pulpit
this is my intention my desire and by the
grace of god i will give you thus said the lord
and of course that inspired commentary from the
pen of ellen white the servant to this church
it is 21 minutes to 12. i am unfamiliar with
when you get out but i'll try to release you
as soon as i possibly can without rushing
the spirit of god is there anyone with us
today you are not a seventh that god bless
you thank you for coming are you together
may the lord bless your lives and guide
you right into his kingdom when he comes
please keep coming to worship with us until that
happy day when i look at you again and i'll be
looking at two members of the seventh they had
for this church can you say amen say it again
anybody else you are not a seventh adventist
nice your hand ah i see a hand moving in
the balcony god bless you thanks for
waving your hand i have picked you out
may the lord bless your life may the
lord grant you the desires of your heart
with such abundance that his goodness to you will
move you to serve him with all your heart and soul
thank you very much worship with
us again any one of us you are not
okay thank you my lovely sister let me take
a chance what's your name say it loudly
okay all right all right well
god knows exactly what it is
thank you very much for coming and may the lord
place a hand of mercy on your life and never
remove it say amen for our sister anyone
else you're not a seventh yeah is that it
well move the hand so i can like that
oh there you are what's your name
what's your
actually god bless your life god bless your family
and god bless you so torrentially that you will
be a blessing to others say amen for ashy anyone
else and i'm not joking these are prayers i'm
praying for our guest this is no joke anybody else
okay did i miss someone where oh hi i see
those two hands thank you for coming is
this your first time you're visiting
with us in the balcony say something
did the person say yes we don't want it to be
the last if you have a need we do not supply it
if you have a sickness may the lord
remove it and if you have an end to me
thanks for coming and god bless
you in every possible way say amen
did you raise your hand
sister or you were saying amen
okay it's uh 19 minutes to 12 and
temples and all things including sermons
before i go any further let me ask you to do three
favors for me favor number one if you have a bible
and the form i prefer that you use
this over there this is the holy bible
this is not the holy iphone are you with
me no i'm quite serious this does not ring
this has no temptation to check whatsapp
instagram the fiber email facebook
whatever else occupies our time this comes loaded
with temptations i was in a hotel room a few
years ago preparing to go speak downstairs
and i was reading the bible on this thing
and these smartphones they have while you're
reading or doing whatever you're doing
an app or something popped up at the bottom of
an advertisement and he said hey are you lonely
no that's what it said it was an advertisement for
dating asian women i was in the room by myself all
i needed to do was take the tip of one finger and
touch it on all the information would have come
to the preacher reading the word of
god what i'm saying to you is this
this does not
it has all the power of the universe
so if you can use one of these
do that if all you saddled with is this then
please don't let it ring in the presence of a
holy god and under no circumstances walk out of
the church to answer the phone unless you're the
physician to the president of the country
and he needs your services other than that
respect the god of heaven and
earth if that's reasonable say amen
the second favor i ask very polite believe me
while i'm speaking all i want you to say is lord
put your words in that man's mouth jeremiah
chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord put forth his hand
and touched my mouth the lord said unto
me behold i have put my words in thy mouth
i only want to speak god's words i
will surely be tempted to speak mine
but my has no my words have no saving value but
the words of god jesus said they are spirit and
their life so ask god to put his words in my mouth
and favor number three i want you to think as you
listen isaiah 118 come now let us reason together
said the lord think as you listen and don't chat
don't do anything to offend the spirit of
god and that also may disturb me let's pray
father in heaven thank you for
allowing me to live to see this day
hearing to listen to your people saying
i thank you for vision to see them and to see
the sunlight and the grass i saw this morning
and the guinea fowl i saw running across
the meadow i thank you dear god for sanity
thank you for the knowledge of jesus christ
one verse says he hath not dealt with us after our
sins nor rewarded us according to our iniquities
dear god thank you for not giving
me the full punishment i deserve
ah god if i've offended you forgive me you know
i'm weak i am dirt i am clay i ask you now lord
through the agency of your spirit take
full possession of my mind my mouth
my heart so that i am simply an instrument in
your hand and let the tune you play is the tune
of truth father bless all those who've come and
a god i ask you to pour out a special blessing
on the visitors touch let this day long remain
in their minds now god bless not only us
but wherever your people are worshiping
you on this holy day your bible sabbath
bless them god bless this country and every
country represented by this congregation
let the leaders always remember in all the
deliberations righteousness exalted the nation and
by the way father remind us exalteth an individual
i commit this message to your glory day god
suppress self i pray in jesus name let god's
people say amen and amen our subject holy for god
our theme is holy for christ the message today
holy for god mark 12 reading from verse 28
mark chapter 12 reading from verse 28. i
read from the king james version of the bible
if you have my version at all times feel free
to read with me mark 12 reading from verse 28.
try to find these passages quickly so i
can move quickly and release you quickly
do you have it now and one of the scribes came
and having heard them reasoning together and
perceiving that he answered them well asked him
which is the first commandment of all and jesus
answered him the first of all the commandment
is here or israel the lord our god is one lord
and thou shalt love the lord thy god save me now
with all thine heart and with all thy soul and
with all thy mind and with all thy strength this
is the first commandment and we stop right there
well let's continue and the second is like namely
this thou shall love thy neighbor as thyself
there is none of the command greater than
these and the scribe said master thou
has said the truth for there is one god one lord
and there is none other than he and to love him
with all the heart and with all the understanding
and with all the soul and with all the strength
and to love his neighbor as himself is more
than all whole burnt offerings and sacrifices
when jesus saw that he answered discreetly he said
unto him thou art not far from the kingdom of god
and no man after that there's to ask him any
question this crime perhaps a lawyer asked jesus
of all the commandments
which is the preeminent one
you see god is a god of degrees
and i don't mean academic degrees
jesus tells us he that love a father and
mother more than me is not worthy of me
what is the conclusion we must love god more than
we love anyone else we must have degrees of love
you must love god more than you love your husband
your wife your children your job your bank account
your friends your shoes we must love
god above everything and everyone else
thou shalt love the lord thy god with all
thy heart and soul and mind and strength
and so the scribe wanted to know what
is the first the chief the preeminent
commandment that stands above all others
ellen white in vision was taken to heaven
and she saw the ark jesus opened it and she saw
the ten commandments each of them had a light
but the fourth had a halo around it which
none of the others had what's the conclusion
of the ten commandments the first
and the chief is commandment four
jesus had 12 named disciples that traveled
with him he had many more than the twelve
but the twelve that traveled with him of
those twelve he was closer to three of them
than he was are you with me god is the
god of degrees he was closer to peter
james and john than he was to the other night
jesus frequented the homes of people he had dinner
in the house of simon the leopard there was a
feast in the house of matthew there was he spent
time in capernaum in the house of peter where he
healed the mother-in-law of peter he spent time
in the home of mary martha and lazarus of all the
homes that jesus visited his favorite was the home
lazarus he preferred to be there more than in any
other home and so we read in desire of 80th page
524 paradigm bless all who sought his help
he loves the whole human family but to some
he is bound by peculiarly tender associations his
heart was lit by a strong bond of affection to
the family at bethany and for one of them his
most wonderful work was wrought she is saying
jesus deliberately reserved his most mighty
miracle for the family closest to him
when god through moses brought
the israelites out of egypt
here's what god told moses to tell the israelites
you've seen what i did unto the egyptians
and how i bear you on eagle's wings and brought
you unto myself now therefore if ye will obey my
choice indeed then keep my covenant then you shall
be a peculiar treasure unto me above all people
god is closer to some than he is to others
deuteronomy 28 verse 1 and it shall come to pass
if thou shalt hearken diligently unto the voice
of the lord thy god i will observe to do all
his commandments which i command thee this day
that the lord thy god shall set me on high above
all nations of the earth i am simply trying
to stress that god is a god of degrees
this functions in heaven as well the highest angel
gabriel has more power than any other angel are
you with me now we apply the principle of degrees
to god's law love for god must take preeminence
over love for our fellow man even though love for
god is expressed through our love for fellow man
but love for god must be preeminent now jesus
told the scribe thou shalt love the lord thy god
i with all thy strength now this
is the first of the two tables
on that table there were four commandments
thou shalt have know the gods before me don't
worship or make idols don't take god's name
in vain and remember the sabbath of the four
the one that identifies who god is
what is office in the universe is and
the territory of his sovereignty the
commandment that does that is command
this is the commandment that is
that identifies god as creator
now god's creatorship if there's such a
word is the foundation of his ownership
let me pause and pray again dear god please
clarify my language help me to make it so
simple the children will understand
and suppress self in jesus name amen
listen to this quotation education
page 137 paragraph four what did i say
education page one please what did i say
that which lies at the foundation of
business integrity and true success
is the recognition of god's ownership
if you're running a business you have a business
you ought to understand first and foremost
everything you have belongs to god
and so elevate counsels us that which lies at the
foundation of business integrity and true success
is the recognition of god's ownership the creator
of all things he is the original proprietor
because he created everything
created belongs to god
1 16 for by him were all things created that
are in heaven and that are in earth visible and
invisible whether they be thrones or dominions or
principalities both things were created by him and
for him and he is before all things and by him all
things consist now when someone reads a passage of
this kind the tendency is to read it casually
and just move on and not pause to grasp the
seriousness and the literal-ness of the passage it
is not found in revelation which is holy symbolic
christ made everything visible invisible in
heaven and in earth which means your mind
belongs to god legally
and i've thrown in the word legally
your senses belong to god legally
your health belongs to god
by right everything we have
rightfully belongs to god except our
sins those rightfully belong to us
are you with me now the ideal human
being is an example for us and who's that
jesus christ as we continue with holy for god
let's look at how jesus conducted his life
in harmony with this concept of holy for god
lord john 7 quickly you read 14 to 16.
john 7 14 to 16 it is precisely 12 o'clock
and i refer to the time from
time to time just to let you know
i am sensitive to time after the
fact you may have other things to do
do you have john amen what verses that i
say 14-16 now about the midst of the feast
jesus went up into the temple and taught and the
jews marveled saying how north this man letters
having never learned jesus answered them
read with me now my doctrine is not mine
come on but his that sent me what
i teach this christ is not mine
so when jesus taught the sabbath he
was teaching what somebody taught him
and who was that someone the father
let me say it again you heard the
words you missed the import of the
word any doctrine jesus christ taught
he taught something that he received from another
source let me add something else in his humanity
he got that doctrine from someone else let's
strengthen this point by going to chapter eight
we read from verse 26. our subject holy for god
i have many things to say and to judge of you
but he that sent me is what true and i speak to
the world what those things which i have heard
of him this is confirmation of what we read
in verse 16 john 7. they understood not that
he spoke to them of the father then said jesus
unto them when you have lifted up the son of man
then shall he know that i am he and that i
do nothing of myself that is not symbolic
when jesus raised lazarus it was
the father who told him to raise him
when jesus told peter come walk in the water to
me it was the father who told him tell him come
now this is strange to your mind and to mine
because we don't allow anyone to tell us anything
mind resists instruction unless it is instruction
for sin don't tell me anything don't advise me
i am 16 don't tell me what
to look for in a boyfriend
i know everything i get cancelled
from my other 16 year old friends
then said he unto them when
you've lifted up the son of man
then shall you know that i am he and that i do
nothing of myself but the father which sent me
he taught me what i should say what
i should speak it is the father
that told jesus what to speak the father taught
him let's go to stage on let's go to verse 37
our subject holy for god our theme holy
for christ i know that you abraham see
but he seek to kill me because my word hath no
place in you let me pause and digress hopefully
meaningfully when god's word does not have a
permanent place in your life and you live long
jesus tells us in john 16 they're doing all
these things to me because they don't know you
let me say it again church membership
is no guarantee of a christian life
church members said crucify him
i know that you're abraham's seed said christ
but you seek to kill me because my word
hath no place in you it has a place on your shelf
it has a place in your pocketbook it has no place
in your heart when the restraining word of god is
not in the life let me say it again that person
under the right provocation continue i know that
you're abraham's seed but you seek to kill me
because my word hath no place in you now listen
carefully i speak that which i have won seen with
my father and ye do that that you have said
with your father jesus says all that i do
i am patterning or i am following
my father's instructions
it is obvious then if you look at john 7
14-16 john 8 26-28 and 37 and other verses
which we can invoke jesus lived entirely come
on for the father his life's theme was holy
in john 6 38.
six minutes after 12.
do you have john 6 verse 38
let me pray again holy father please god
tighten your grip on my mind my mouth
whatever i require to express
this message you control it
for your glory and our blessing in jesus name i
pray amen john 6 38 for i came down from heaven
what not to do my own will but
the will of him that's something
this is
what every other so-called
child of god should follow
i have to keep saying that these
words are not symbolic because
i don't think you've that has
registered in your minds yet
let me say differently by giving you this one of
the most beautiful quotations you can read in any
book whether written by ella white or socrates or
whomever the desire of ages page 20 paragraph two
there is nothing save the selfish heart of man
that lives unto itself no bird that claims the air
no animal that moves upon the ground but
ministers to some other life there is no
leaf of the forest or lowly blade of grass but
has its ministry every tree and shrub belief
pours forth that element of life without which
neither man nor animal could live and man
an animal in turn minister to the life of tree
and shrug a leaf the flowers breathe fragrance and
unfold the beauty and blessing to the world the
sun sheds its light to gladly a thousand worlds
the ocean itself the source of all our springs
and fountains receives the streams from every land
but takes to give the mists ascending from
its bosom fall in showers to water the earth
that it may bring forth and bud what is
the condensed meaning of that quotition
everything created was created
to serve something else
now when you read where she says every
blade of grass has its ministry when you
leave you'll see grass pause and look at one
blade of grass and let your mind be challenged
these concepts are foreign to us because our
minds are tainted but that thing is to be
gradually removed by consistent exposure
to the divine radiation of god's word
take this now and apply to human beings
you and i were not created for our sakes
we were created for the glory of god
in other words you have nothing to do with you
one person understood what i just said let me
say it again you have nothing to do with you
i have nothing to do with me i am on this earth
someone read my mind and finish my thought for god
at the risk of being tedious this is not symbolic
we must live lives holy for god as g or for
christ as jesus lived his life holy for god
understand this the interaction between christ
and god is the model for the interaction
between us and christ you missed it my fault
let me say differently the way christ
interacted with the father is precisely the way
must interact with christ
in the light of this message as verily
as christ lived his life holy for god
finish my thoughts we must live our
lives holy christ which is our theme
genesis 1 26 don't go there see and
god said let us make man in our image
before sin there was one image when adam sinned
a second one popped up if adam hadn't sinned all
his children would have been born in god's
image because adam had no image of his own
a friend of mine asked me many years ago
he said randy when do i express myself
and i responded with one word
hopefully i was clear never
this is one of the problems in the church
when it comes to fashion i want to express
myself that's why i wear what i wear i'll fix
my hair do i fix it or buy the shoes i buy
i want to say to the world sartorially this is me
which is also an expensive way
to rebel are you following me
it's a form of rebellion because sin is rebellion
you are not in this earth to express yourself
you and i are on this earth
finish my words to express god
this is not my conclusion this is the bible first
corinthians 10 31 say it with me whether therefore
you eat or drink or whatsoever you do now
you tell me what is excluded from whatsoever
nothing finish the verse now do all do you have
much how much finish it now to the glory of god
listen to me this is not symbolic
first peter chapter 1 verse 15. go there with me
let's see how it supports first corinthians 10 31.
towards the back of the bible
you should bump into first peter
do you have it now 14 after
12 find it find it please
that's the problem with screens you see we no
longer know how to find the books in the bible
and phones you see this all right
she finally found it
first peter 115 what does it say but as he which
have called you come on is holy finish the verse
so be holy carefully now really microscopically
finish the verse in all manner of conversation
what's our theme what's
this is the first peter 1 15 again but
as he which have called you is holy
when is god not holy on tuesday
it's not only holy on sabbath
the bible says as he which have called
you is holy so be holy in all manner
of conversation go to first timothy
chapter four victory verse eight
first timothy four listen to the apostle paul
writing to a young man and of course a young lady
will benefit just as much because truth applies to
everyone first timothy chapter 4 reading verse 8.
we have it now
for bodily exercise come on profited
little but godliness come on is
profitable come on unto all things
when you buy clothes be driven by godliness
when you at the right age set your eyes on a young
lady be driven by godliness not her hips and lips
when you consider an academic degree
that will cost your parents so much money
be driven finish my words by god when
you go to wherever restaurants you go
and you have the menu and it's
your whole list of dead animals
finish my words be driven
by god whether therefore ye
for bodily exercise prophetess little but
godliness is profitable unto all things now
finish the verse microscopically having
promised come on of the life that now is
end of the life to come godliness
extends beyond this life
when this is the way you live your life
then you and i will match our fear holy
for christ as christ was holy for god
whether therefore he eat or drink allah so ever
you do we do not believe that kind of approach
feel that approach
and narrow and opposed to our freedom
because our natural condition is to
see the benefits of sin and to view
the horrors of holiness and so when the devil
spoke to eve he said you shall not surely die
although i've been saying if the deity eat
thereof give me one word for that disobedience
give me a smaller version of disobedience sing
in the daily sin but he does not use that word if
you eat thereof then your eyes shall be
open benefit one it had no foundation too
knowing good and evil the devil presented
sin as attractive he never used the word sin
or disobedience and he did
his work of marketing so well
that eve bought the product
see a good thing at the store we go tell our
friends so she met her husband and he went along
my brothers and sisters if they had
followed the principle of forgotten
holy for god they would never have eaten
of that fruit many of you are in college
how many of you are in college makes your
hands a university some form of all right
let me i guess what
cranial nerves but i will not do that
are you studying medicine tell me loudly
you want to help people and you said it because
you guessed that's what i wanted to hear
anyone else who raised the hair
i'm quite serious anyone else raise
the hand oh yes what do you study
now under the force of honesty
and in the presence of a holy god surrounded
by witnesses why did you choose physics
okay but it had nothing to do
with god no but you're a christian
and that's a problem here's
a christian who does things
had no connections with god you see when someone
the chance of a degree must be driven
by godliness in other words how
will this advance the glory of god
let me tell you something listen
carefully this is why we're not blessed
do not belong to god
even though you pursue it with the brain i
now god is so good they are
general blessings that god bestows
matthew 5 45 he makes his son to rise on
the evil and on the good and send a rain on
the ones that cause the angels to marvel they
are reserved for those who live holy for christ
let me tell you something god bless is what's his
when your life is not his
yes god will sprinkle some blessings
on you just to preserve you
so you come to the place where you
accept him then he can send a tsunami
there are christians blaming god god is
not nice to me he has given me nothing
your life does not belong to god he has no legal
[ __ ] to pour out the fullness of his blessing
testimonies volume 5 is 341 paragraph
1 fallen man is satan's lawful captive
there is a degree of legality not
legalism legality because we have a law
fallen man is satan's lawful capital the sinner
rightfully and legally belongs to the savior
i didn't say the person who
occasionally makes a mistake no
i said the sinner whose lifestyle
that's the lifestyle that person
lawfully belongs to the devil and god
does not pour out blessings in heaven
but he wants to bless your lives
so he tells you come to me leave where you
are and come let me change my words call
me and i will break you out from where you
are because you can't leave are you falling
i mean holy for christ so that when you see jesus
said to philip john 14 and i'm coming to the close
philip said in john 14 verse 8 lord show us the
father and it sufficeth us before i go any further
let me pray again god in heaven let me not drift
into self-expression but god i offer myself as
your servant your slave you tell me what to say
i'll say it in jesus name amen philip says unto
him lord show us the father and it suffices us
jesus said unto him have i been so long time with
you and yet has thou not known me fella he that
have seen me you finish it have seen the father
now this is jesus and the father that's holy for
the father you and i must come to the place where
it can be saved he that have seen them finish
my words have seen jesus this is not symbolic
if you look at christ you look at the believer
you're not sure who's who because they are alike
the humanity of christ is our example and christ
this is a while christ lives such a powerful life
desire of idiot space 664
paragraph four what did i say
how many of you wrote it
down ah god bless your sister
christ revealed no qualities
and exercised no powers
his perfect humanity is that which
all his followers may possess
what is she saying we can live
the life that jesus christ lived
not in our strength because christ did not
live in history listen to how the quotation
ends his perfect humanity is that which all his
followers may possess if they will be in subjects
you know why christ has not yet come
it is not because we need more advertised colleges
to become universities that's not why he has to
come it is not because we need to build more
hospitals that's not why he doesn't come
or people need to have more children
we are not yet living holy for
christ christ is waiting with
longing desire for the manifestation of himself in
his people when the character of christ shall be
in his church his people say he will come
to claim them to zone so the delay of christ
is because the church is not holy for christ
and then we blame the papacy
you know god is not waiting
for the papacy to do anything
he's waiting for us we blame the illuminati
we blame the muslims they're hard to win we
blame the hindus they're hard to win we blame
the buddhists they're hard to win the hardest
people god had to deal with were the israelites
you couldn't win them are you listening to
me my brothers and sisters children of god
make a decision because if your life is not you
see the only way god can save you well let me
say differently holy for god holy for christ
if you surrender to christ 99 you're lost
you see the devil only needs
one percent to destroy your life
all of me in order to save me so his desire
for holy for god and holy for christ is not
based on self-centeredness it is based on our the
only way god can save you is if you're holy heals
i'll express it differently matthew 10 37
he that loveth father and mother more than
me is not worthy of me christ is saying i must be
first you see god can only save us if he occupies
bishop cannot save you from position two
you're not listening
i have to say it again
it is only when god is first in my life it is only
from that vantage position that he can save me
any other position and the advantage goes to the
enemy and so this thing holy or holy for christ
is very very serious and when i deal
with end time events this afternoon
i will come at it in a very very different
way i have nothing to say about the people
the little time of jacob's trouble
the big time of jacob's trouble
the sunday law the close of probation
the following of this everlast plague
i have nothing to do with that
but i will discuss end times
i have a question for you don't answer me
have you given your life entirely to christ
answers no do it before you leave
do it before you get out of your chair
because death does not send a text
neither god not the devil sends a text to
tell you this is your last moment on earth
are you with me do not leave this
building without giving your life
entirely to christ to god having heard what
you've heard do not leave this building with
the arrogance that i'll still continue to
live do i live because i'll be alive five
years from now and just before the close
of probation i will give my life to christ
do it before you leave because the most blessed
life is a life that is placed in the hands of god
because those in his hands cannot be plucked out
yes jesus came face to face with the demoniac
of the gatherings and the description of the
man is such that neither could any man tame him
or bind him because that he had been often bound
with feathers and chains and the chains had
been plucked asundered by him and defectors
broken in pieces neither could he maintain him
and always in the day and night he was in the
mountains and in the tombs crying and cutting
himself with stone people saw him unravelled
no one could restrain him that's the
devil but when he saw jesus afar off
he ran and worshiped him and cried with
loud voices and said gee what if i to
thee jesus now son the most high god i will
journey by god that thou told made you not
but he had said unto him come out of the man the
unclean spirit and jesus asked him what is thy
name and he answered saying my name is legion
for we are many now listen to verse 10. this
is the demon now and he besought him much that
he would not send them away out of the country
the demons begged jesus
don't send this away verse 11 now there was
there nigh unto the mountains a great herd
of slight feeding and all the devils besought him
to beseech his debate send us into the swine that
we may enter into them unfortunately jesus gave
them leave and the unclean spirits entered into
the swine of the herd ran fire with me down the
steep place into the sea what i'm trying to tell
you that 2 000 demons up against one man named
that one man jesus christ and they all begged him
when your life is in the hands
of god satan has to beg god
and so jesus said to peter simon simon satan have
desired to see have you that he may seek to his
weak but i have prayed for thee the devil went
to jesus for permission but if [ __ ] simon peter
had not been a child of god satan needs
no permission to harass his own people
am i talking to myself let me close the book as
a visual symbol i am about to end when your life
belongs to god the devil needs permission when
your life does apply for god's sweetest blessings
when your life belongs to god the devil will
complain to god as he complained about job has not
thou made a hedge about him and about his house
and about all that he have on every side some
people the businesses keep failing because they
don't belong to god and so they try and it fails
they try and it fails they try and it fails why
because the glory of god was not the motivation
and some go to school no tuition no
tuition why because the chance of a degree
had nothing to do with the glory of god the
universe are under the control of christ
for your blessing that's not my view that's the
bible and what is the power to us according to
the working of his mighty power which he wrought
in christ when he raised him from the dead and set
him at his own right hand in the heavenly places
far above all principalities and powers and might
and dominions and every name that is named not
only in this world but also that which is to come
and hath put all things under his feet and gave
him to be the head over all things to the church
let me say it again all the treasures of heaven
are in the command of christ for the blessing
but we must live our lives three words tell
me holy for christ give christ your education
give him your bank account give him your
romantic life give him your family life
give him your recreational life
give him your house and not just give him your car
let me tell you what happened to me that i
closed many many years ago i had a little
honda crx they don't make them anymore a little
carvey dude loved it and i used to drive very fast
the lord cured me of that painlessly and one day
i was in the parking lot about to go somewhere
and i said father this car is yours you gave me
the money to buy i'll drive it on your chauffeur
i'll put in the gas change the old italian but
it is yours and i acknowledge this car as yours
what i'm about to tell you is fact two weeks
later they checked the mileage just out of cue
not connected to what i said to god you know just
checking how my car was performing i was getting
10 more miles per gallon than i was before because
i checked it i used to get 36 miles to the gallon
when i dedicated the car to god and it had
nothing to do with my weight my mileage went
to 46 miles per hour many of us are sick because
our bodies do not belong to god mind character
and personality volume 1 page 34 paragraph 3.
i want to ask you what he said hello i write
let the mind become intelligent and
the will be placed on the lord's side
and there will be a wonderful improvement in
the physical health without doing anything else
a surrender of the life to god wholly completely
and without reservation creates immediately
an improvement in you're not visiting the
pharmacist or the chemist whatever you call them
i know i'm repetitious but i'm compelled to
be give your life to god without reservation
you ask how do i do that you just do it you say
lord here is my life let me say it again if your
life does not belong to god it is not god's
fault that he cannot bless the way he wants to
give your love to god and for
those who do not know how to say
lord i give you my life then say to god
father i don't know how to give it i ask you
but take it and be the god of my life
how many of you will say father and say
it seriously god doesn't joke there are
no jokes in the bible father to the best of my
ability i give you my life my education my health
my dress choices my eating choices my romantic
choices i commit all of that to you to the best of
my ability if you say that there's your right hand
don't look around just keep looking straight up
quietly quiet
father if i preach badly forgive me if
i was a little too hard on your children
and you do not take it lightly when they're
treated harshly my intention their father
was to impress upon them the importance of
living holy for christ of a god that we will
live only for jesus as he lived only for you
no variation they got precisely the same way
where i fell short let the spirit make up
the difference father now god in the name of
jesus christ who came in our fallen nation
and demonstrated how to live only for god
in his name by the power of his life accept
those who make commitments right in your presence
to give the life completely to you father help
them to understand this commitment must be renewed
every day i pray father even now as they stand
that you will grant them a measure of your spirit
that will sustain them in this decision which the
devil doesn't like but all of heaven is rejoicing
please god help them to understand in the youth in
the figure of youth their god that the sooner the
life is given completely to you is the more
likely it is to live a life free of regrets
because so many regrets are
rooted in youthful decisions
please that young man who's hesitated trouble
that young lady who's so fascinated by the
world she realizes to commit her life to you
will have her separating from the world and
she is caught between heaven and hell father by
this power of the spirit just nudge her over the
line on the side of heaven she'll be glad you did
please father give us a hatred for the world and
the love for the things of heaven your servant
writes in the review on herald january 24 1880
if your thoughts your plans your purposes are
all directed toward the accumulation of the
things of earth your anxiety your study your
interests will all be centered upon the world
the heavenly attractions will lose their beauty
the glories of the eternal world will cease to
have the force of reality to you and this is
the condition many of us are in because our
minds are on the earth not in heaven i ask
you one more time holy father in humility
acknowledging our sin help us to understand the
importance it is important that it stretches to
eternity the importance of living holy
for christ this is why we're given life
and your servant writes in historical sketches
page 285 paragraph 4 every youth should be
impressed with the fact that he's not his own that
his strength his time his talents belong to god
it should be his chief purpose in life to glorify
god and to do good to his fellow man please father
reach these young people particularly
because all things being equal to have
a long life ahead of them if christ still
delays let them find their greatest joy
in reflecting you and let their lives lead
others to jesus please hear me not just the
young bless everyone under the sound of my voice
ease our burdens day god wipe away our tears
and bless us i pray in jesus name and
for his sake let god's people say amen